keep being invited you know what what
one word would you use to describe China
and I'm like well I don't do that to any
other country in the world if no one
invites we say give me one word to
describe the UK's relationship with
France
I mean it's just and it's weird you know
our relationship with China just like
our relationship with every other
country around the world it's
complicated it's multifaceted there are
things that countries do that we agree
with and seek to support there are even
with our closest friends there are
things that they do that we might
disagree with and we raise those issues
with them so the idea of of giving this
one word to descriptor to China where we
don't do it with any other country in
the world I think is I think is
um I think he's foolish